Activists like Dr. Madeha Al Ajroush have been lobbying for decades...
...for the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia to allow women to drive.
By next summer, Dr. Madeha will be allowed to drive...
...without risking arrest, fines and punishment.
The new policy will allow women to obtain a driver's license...
...without having to ask permission of a husband, father or male guardian.
The Kingdom's representative to the United Nations talked about the policy...
...during a meeting at the UN.
This is a historic day for Saudi society for men and women and we can now say, "At last".
Saudi Arabia is hoping the policy will help the economy...
...and increase the role of women in the workforce.